here's what would happen if titanosaurus  never went extinct  titanosaurus were herbivores that ate a  broad range of plants because their  massive size their top speed only  averaged around 8 kilometers an hour if  they were around in the present day  evolving titanosaurs could deplete the  ecosystem of vegetation and might be  forced to become omnivores  this could create a scary ripple effect  in the food chain possibly causing other  species to die off  since it's possible that we would be  considered prey humans would be forced  to live in treetops  but if we chose to hunt these creatures  imagine how many mouths we could feed  the titanosaur could become a source of  food for humans which might even solve  world hunger  this could force them to flee land and  head to the water they'd survive on a  plethora of underwater marine life and  plankton  disrupting the ocean ecosystems so